team white or black team white okay
let's go with well we don't know just
yet takes two players to determine an
opening you can't just go right out and
say that this is the English can you
okay let's see alright let's get some
center built up and it's being hit right
away it's my opponent gonna take this
night out after d5 Bishop takes Knight
let's see yes okay so I'm kind of uh I
think they've been studying this is uh
where's where's Roman
gingy house really where is he where is
he okay how do I deal with this
imbalance this bishop could turn out to
be dead this seems very natural I have a
feeling that my opponents gonna crush me
let's see let's see about that what if I
play this to to mess with stuff okay
just to mess with the structure let's
see what how black responds to that make
that pond flinch as well makes okay I
could already start to anticipate the
bishop has to come off on this diagonal
I'm I might be quite alright with just
giving this pawn up keep in mind it's
the dark square bishop that they gave up
and so without this pawn around the
bishop can really show itself on that
corner to corner diagonal in castling
kingside
maybe not the greatest thing in the
world so at least my opponent is a bit
confused I would I'm thinking by having
them not move so quickly and what should
I be doing should I just take that pawn
should I just take him
before this this pond could play Island
let's just take them
now this pond is backwards these two
guys are probably ugliest ponds around
double isolated ponds they want to avoid
that let's see what should I be doing
night out is my first thought should I
go with instead g3 Bishop g2 before this
Bishop gets on this diagonal or is it
even gonna go there I'm not gonna show
my hand just yet maybe I want to come
out in this diagonal maybe this one I
think this is the better one to be
perfectly honest I don't know what kind
of a future my bishop would have just
kind of going to d3 or e2 just kind of
staring at ponds and like I was saying
I'm not I'm kind of just content with
saying go ahead take that pond I don't
care about him he is in my eyes just
expendable so if you really want to take
on my bishops gonna turn into the big
bad wolf a machine I think I certainly
see compensation I mean it might just be
flat-out bad like there might be some
winning continuation can I go as far as
saying that we're gonna see about that
now are we ok Queen c2 yeah Queen c2 my
queen is hit seems like the most natural
square and now here comes the dangerous
dark square bishop who would otherwise
have maybe some issues with contributing
that's a really really really good
diagonal um I could have gone there
right away if I wanted to but I see no
need he's that what you would call the
x-factor bishop the unopposed bishop
most dangerous guy around as soon as you
give up your dark square bishop
is your opponents dark square bishop in
most cases and I believe that this is
one of those cases so if I just do this
there's gonna be castle so maybe this is
worth considering actually I didn't
consider it on the last move but maybe I
want to stop castling or you know what
maybe I'm okay with allowing castling
and I just want to play for maid on h8
let's go here another thing is that I
think I can at this point
avoid castling kingside I don't know
that there is a need to Castle kingside
okay now with that clearly we're not
gonna be having kingside castle so where
is that King gonna go he's gonna go
Queen side isn't he that's logical that
makes sense all right let's castle I
think this is that means it's got to be
a good dog and I'll still maybe I could
what can I do
um let me challenge this night gotta get
rid of him the one that's in my position
the piece that's in my position is the
one that's usually most annoying he's
he's the one that's most annoying so
he's hit three times I don't know that
it could be maintained black I guess
could maybe be throwing in night before
stuff but I think okay well let's see
they did do that
I can't move my queen and still maintain
pressure on this night so that's a bit a
bit of a pain but okay let's just die
run home this night can't do anything
just yet
and I might have to just kind of go back
at that so let me let me kick this night
away and then come back here oh no no no
I could take care I'm gonna go here with
my bishop and then my knight but then
after queenside castle this pawn is
defended in my light squares are weak
hang on hang on for a second let me just
defend this guy and now Queen c2 next so
earlier I was thinking there was going
to be compensation but maybe I'm not so
sure let's see I'm gonna give up this
Knight or just run away um down on time
okay I'm able to get this guy I don't
know that that could be was that really
a good thing to do maybe now I should
take with the bishop and then Queen
takes I just don't like that
oh I could do that actually because
there's pins there's pins here I'm
guarding this twice as well I was
thinking they couldn't take because I
could take like this but I'm just
guarding it twice as is I have pressure
on this diagonal I'm I've regained that
material the bishop is pinned I think I
want to chase this night away or
something
mmm you get my rook doing something I
also should have been a bit more
cautious about f2 now it's not Sun
protected attacked once defended once
this is an issue so the Queen going to
the F file I have to be careful do I
want to play this move okay is that I'm
just gonna get two minor pieces missing
whoa
my opponents gonna be hitting a lot of
stuff here wow that scares me actually
that scares me the the rooks start to
become pigs my second rank 37 seconds I
gotta go quicker I want to play III okay
is that night really gonna play here it
might be tempting to do that okay I got
that pawn back I'm still down stuff
though that Knights gonna get that
Bishop back although no I should have I
should have maybe I'm not on this now
right here I think it's best just get
this guy in the corner okay now I still
keep the bishop hair where's that Knight
gonna go okay my rooks I don't know how
great they are Bishop here they're
covering a lot of squares yeah I could
give a check actually I missed that I
could be giving a check here 26 seconds
okay this is the bishop has to come back
definitely has to come back to defend
and I think I want to avoid the bishop
exchange actually come back here maybe I
could give check maybe push the bishop
away as well okay now now that bishop is
close to trapped bishop check I should
just picked up the night now I have it
at least about even on time now
also my bishop can my bishops control
all entry points I can improve my King
position let's walk this King up push
here kick the rook away maybe King G to
h3 let's try that again still all entry
points are covered I'll just take that
King here if there's a rook check okay
my opponent is flying now the King gets
pushed back okay there's nothing to
really do at this point okay they're
down on time oh man
bishop hair good game
let's go back I think I'm pretty sure
that's like the first time playing the
gingy Indian where you give up that dark
square bishop but I don't know about
really taking on c3 and being able to
get away with it it just seems like a
half compensation although you did well
to of course make the decision to knock
Castle kingside for one and go Queen
side but let's see
f5 d6 is this how black should be
treating this d6 move there's not too
many more pawn moves that can change the
structure I wonder if I wonder if just
um playing east six is better is this
pawn going to be too much of an issue or
could what about a five if a five could
I go pawn hunting with Queen d5 I'm
really not sure what to suggest here
my opponent is saying that the c3
capture is a line that they've looked at
and I really I don't really don't have a
lot to offer on it I know that you
really do have to be careful again grab
grabbing that c3 pawn I'm just wondering
what the what the correct decision
should be for black is it okay to do the
move they played with Knight f6 or
should the Queen maybe be coming out to
tart I don't know I just don't know the
candidate moves at least I would be
looking at our East six you're really
weak in your dark squares I just don't
know maybe Knight f6 is okay just
development let's go with that 94 he
turned out to be a monster he was not so
easy to get rid of and you went for that
pawn grab and it seems like you're gonna
be okay actually I like these moves that
this move ensures that this night we'll
be able to stick around for a little bit
more I didn't really have anything
better I had to go back home or to see
one somewhere on the first rank and in
the meantime you're not too far off from
castling and i think i could go wrong
very easily right here okay you dropped
upon was that necessary for you to drop
that pod maybe just take mmm I'm not so
sure you take a recapture I'll have a
lot of I have all the Senate I have a
lot of control over the center I don't
know I guess taking was another move but
right here I'm really glad that I didn't
take this Knight rook takes Knight and
see if I was correct with these
calculations rook takes Knight Bishop
takes Queen takes Queen takes e two is
just hitting everything Queen rook
bishop pun I think she's intolerable I
got a taker in the rook then recaptures
and then the rook is hitting my bishop
and you're hitting f2 twice I gotta move
my bishop or do
defend them and then you grab on f2 that
there's two pigs there versus the rooks
I don't know
- two rooks on my second rank versus my
two bishops I think your rucks are doing
better yeah
so that's that's why I just dropped back
like that and at this point I think you
are better right here I think you should
go with the knight b3 you're hitting
everything you're defending this pond
you force my rook into the corner and
then well alright we're still balanced
with the material but you I think we'll
have a faster track towards the center
with your King and I think that that one
factor at least is tipping in your favor
come an endgame phase so Knight b3
whatever somewhere on the first you grab
the bishop and then or maybe not even
maybe you could just hold off night here
I can't even do a counter attacking
Musso Knight b3 I go here if I'm going
here I'm defending the rook so ok Knight
b3 just just take that bishop I don't
have that advantage of the bishop here
anymore and then it becomes who could
get a better King position endgame who
could get their pawns rolling and I
think your pawns are better equipped to
get going faster you're even stepping up
one with tempo on the King there's a
small little detail but at this point we
are doing what we are trying to go fast
so we don't lose on time okay a very
good game mr. Allan chests very
interesting I got a little bit more
experience with that particular line
it's cool different pawn structure to
work with not not so typical